Unlike other genres, action movies don't need
to be filled with nuanced performances or
a watertight plot.
If anything, those things just get in the
way of the face-punching.
All a good action movie needs is a sky-high
bullet budget, some flippy kicks, and kerosene
burning through its veins from start to finish.
Fortunately, Netflix is jammed full of underrated
action movies.
If you'd rather see bruised chins than Oscar
wins, this action movie roundup will be right
up your alley.
Skin Trade
Dolph Lundgren, Ron Perlman, Michael Jai White,
and Tony Jaa sounds like a dream action movie
cast if we've ever seen one, and Skin Trade
delivers on that promise in spades.
Granted, the plot is pretty flimsy—it's
basically cops and robbers in Thailand—but
the thrill of seeing these action legends
all in one place doesn't wear off.
Lundgren manages to keep up with the much
younger and more agile Jaa in some wild action
scenes, and Jai White is, as always, a magnetic
on-screen talent.
Come for the talent lineup.
Stay for the insanity and fist fights.
Savage Dog
Scott Adkins is pretty much the undisputed
king of direct-to-DVD action movies these
days, and Savage Dog is an impressive entry
in his filmography.
We rarely get to see Adkins in a period piece,
and even though he still mostly just beats
people up, he gets to do it in different costumes
this time.
But beyond the unusual setting, Savage Dog
is still something special.
The movie opens with Adkins' character digging
his way out of a shallow grave, which is the
only way to start a movie like this.
The film then goes back in time, catching
us up to the moment of his burial and then
sending him on a brutal path of revenge featuring
some stunning fight sequences.
Adkins' filmography is littered with cool
action hits, but Savage Dog is a clear high
point.
Bullet to the Head
Released in 2013, Bullet to the Head comes
from Walter Hill, director of the 1979 cult
classic The Warriors.
It's pure grindhouse fun, which is exactly
what a Walter Hill action flick starring Sylvester
Stallone should be.
Bullets fly, bodies drop, and cars are blown
to bits over the course of the movie.
It's a great time, solidified by Jason Momoa's
role as the film's villain.
You don't want to miss it.
Boyka: Undisputed
Scott Adkins headlines the later installments
of the Undisputed series as Yuri Boyka, a
prison inmate who participates in a brutal
underground prison fighting ring.
Boyka: Undisputed sees Boyka released from
prison and fighting professionally, but the
fight scenes are just as stylish and brutal
as any that came before this in the series.
Four movies in, Undisputed is as fun as it's
ever been.
Bring on the next one.
Small Soldiers
Children of the '90s are likely to remember
the toys that spawned from director Joe Dante's
Small Soldiers, along with the crushing disappointment
that they didn't actually come to life and
try to blow up your house.
"Let me see that weapon.
Standard issue is insufficient."
The film itself is something of a forgotten
gem—and one that's definitely made for a
younger audience—but an action movie is
an action movie, and this one is actually
a lot of fun.
Small Soldiers is weird, campy, and features
action figures going to war with each other,
which, for most kids, was the best toy-based
combat outside of Toy Commander for the Sega
Dreamcast.
Sky Captain and the World of Tomorrow
In a just world, Sky Captain and the World
of Tomorrow would have been a box office smash
and ushered in a new era of elegant, stylistic
action cinema.
Drawing heavily from pulp cinema and comic
books, Sky Captain is a wild romp through
a steampunk reimagining of a pre-World War
II world.
The titular Sky Captain is a charismatic ace
pilot who leads the daredevil Flying Legion.
Played by Jude Law, he's joined by reporter
Polly Perkins and a brief appearance by Angelina
Jolie as the eyepatched Royal Navy officer
Franky Cook.
It's a great cast heading up a fun, visually
inventive action film that deserves a far
larger fan following than it has today.
Officer Downe
Want to watch the craziest movie on Netflix?
Officer Downe has you covered.
Adapted from the comic by writer Joe Casey
and artist Chris Burnham, there shouldn't
be a way to translate this insanity from page
to screen.
And yet the film manages to pull it off.
Starring Kim Coates of Sons of Anarchy fame,
it's a hyperkinetic neon thrill ride that
plays out like Judge Dredd in a fever dream.
This movie has everything: nuns with guns,
an immortal super cop, and a hidden government
conspiracy.
What more could you ask for?
Fighting
It's kind of hard to remember the days when
Channing Tatum wasn't a megastar, but back
before Magic Mike and 21 Jump Street, Tatum
appeared in this little-seen gem.
Tatum plays the tough-as-nails Shawn, a hustler
who discovers he's a prodigy as a street fighter.
The fight scenes are brutal, no-holds-barred
affairs that translate the intensity of street
fighting to the screen very well.
Fighting was never going to win any Oscars,
but it's a very interesting, and often overlooked
entry in a talented actor's career.
Death Sentence
Modern horror master James Wan — of Saw,
Insidious and The Conjuring fame — took
a brief hiatus from the genre in 2007 with
Death Sentence, a Kevin Bacon vehicle that
follows the tried-and-true narrative of a
regular man out for revenge.
When his son is stabbed in a gang initiation
ritual, Bacon's Nick Hume decides to take
the law into his own hands, waging a one-man
war on crime in his city.
It's nothing action fans haven't seen before
— but you haven't seen this kind of film
directed by a wiz like James Wan or with an
actor so effortlessly good as Kevin Bacon.
Bacon channels Nick's relentless drive, grief,
and rage in stunning, understated fashion.
Throw in John Goodman as the film's villain
and you've got yourself a good time.
It may be familiar action movie territory,
but sometimes that just means it's worth the
journey.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!